[Music]
this is the outskirts of Baidoa
in southwest and Somalia and it's the
location of a project being financed by
the German government behind these thick
bullet-ridden walls is a Center for
Somali Xterra fighters many may be used
to firing weapons but now they're
learning how to become electricians or
builders it's hoped around 100 men can
be reintegrated into society under
watchful eyes all of them are former
members of the Somali terror group
al-shabaab Noah was just 15 when he
joined the militants together with
almost everyone else he knew
I was young there was no work nothing
for us to do and al-shabab rebelled
against his poverty and the government
knew it says he can't remember how many
people he had to kill when his brother
died in the fighting it all became too
much and he deserted earn money with Al
Shabab and build a life for myself but
there was only death it was much worse
than before al Shabab is often called
Africa's Taliban it's fighting to
establish an Islamic state in the Horn
of Africa the group controls some parts
of Somalia but he's been driven out
elsewhere mainly by troops from
neighboring Kenya
al-shabab executed an attack on a
shopping center in Nairobi in September
2013 that killed 67 people Noah and the
other men here weren't so fanatical but
even as simple foot soldiers there was
subject to brainwashing reversing that
will take time the hope is that now the
teachings of moderate Islam may help the
religious leader helping them is risking
his life and doesn't want to give his
name doesn't stop me it's there anyway
whether I preach here or outside and to
moderate for hours about they want to
kill me anyway so I'd rather stay here
and help these young men and my country
the head of the D radicalization center
is convinced that the concept works and
that young men like nur can successfully
be reintegrated into society cannot be
the solution all the time so this has to
do with parallel otherwise things would
not end up that we chose plan so the
only thing is that it's just a proper
notion but we need for dinner I believe
to do more the same the men are being
taught the basics of economics and how
to run a successful enterprise Noah's
dream is to run his own tailoring
business
my wish is to be back as a part of
society to have my business and live a
normal peaceful life we learn little my
son don't let me tell you what are you
laying in bed it's not yet clear of
people like no can be reintegrated after
a year and a half in the program but
it's an attempt and something more and
more countries are having to consider
exactly what to do with former
extremists